here
One of the Pharisees asked Jesus to eat
with him.
He went into the Pharisees house and reclined at
table.
And behold a woman of the city who was
a sinner.
When she learned that he was reclining at table in the Pharisees house
brought in Alabaster flask of ointment perfume.
Standing behind him at his feet weeping. She
began to wet his feet with her tears and wiped
them with the hair of her head and kissed his feet
and anointed them with the ointment.
Now when the Pharisee who had invited him saw this he said
to himself if this man were a prophet
He would have known who and what sort of woman this
is who is touching him?
For she is a sinner.
Now if you were there at that dinner.
Watching this unfold how would you have responded?
Now it might be easy for us 2,000 years later to
sit back and condemnation over this Pharisee.
This Jewish religious leader that what he
was muttering to himself like many so judgmental and we look
at that from this side, but don't be too quick to cast the
first stone.
Because this man would not have been alone in that judgment.
Others would have thought the same thing.
Right because because prophets and Priests and
other leaders at that time. They had a lawful requirement to
separate from sinners.
To avoid becoming unclean so that
they could enter into the temple to worship.
Like this was just part of the deal.
And women like this.
Were perpetually unclean.
That's why he thinks what he thinks.
And it's how most if not all of the religious leaders at
that time would have thought focused on the law
the Holiness codes and and the cleanliness side of
life. They were focused so much.
But Jesus was different.
We see that all over the gospels the way he treated
people.
The way he healed people.
The way he went about proclaiming the good news of
God's kingdom coming.
But also as we'll see today.
the way Jesus forgave big sinners
He was different the way he forgave big
Sinners. That's the point today
that Jesus forgave big Sinners. I know it sounds over simplified.
Just wait it out. You'll you'll see some things. I think
you might not have seen before.
Because remember The Parables revealed to us the the backwards
nature of God's kingdom compared to the way of the
world.
That things are different in God's kingdom. They
show us the values and the Heart of the king first and his
kingdom.
Including this parable of the two debtors that we
will find in Luke 7.
So take your copy of God's word and turn there with me to Luke chapter 7
again all summer in the parables in
Luke Luke 7 is where we'll find this one.
Already read verses 36 to 39 at the
start which gives us the context of this scene
that Jesus had been invited into this Pharisees house for a meal.
That's where this woman found Jesus. They
she'd heard he was there and she was so moved by
being with him by being near him that that she
was she was doing what she did there.
This woman remember that that Luke makes it a point to mention
twice than in people's eyes. She was a sinner.
So people perceived her.
This woman was that Jesus's feet.
Notice not even in front of him, but behind him
she was so broken and low. She would just crawled
up behind his feet.
And then you have this this Pharisee over in the corner.
Just you can just see him right sitting back. Just muttering.
judging
both Jesus and the woman
now verse 40
look at it says Jesus answering now remember?
This guy was talking to himself, right?
So Jesus reads his mind. First of all, that's kind of scary first as
you're imagining judging someone in Jesus
says hey, hey Simon, right, so he read
the guy's Minds at Simon. I have something to say to you.
And so Simon answered say it teacher.
In other words Simon I know what you're thinking man.
Someone teach you a lesson.
And so in response to the whole scene here at this
meal where the woman is weeping and
anointing his feet the Pharisees over here judging Jesus
tells the parable of the
two debtors.
Look at verses 41 through 43.
Certain money lender had two debtors.
one owed 500 Denari the
other 50
when they could not pay he canceled the debt of
both.
Now which of them will love him more?
And Simon answered the one I suppose for whom
he canceled the larger debt.
And Jesus said to him you have judged rightly.
Now it seems simple but we need to understand what Jesus
was teaching here, right?
We need to understand the point of Jesus's parable.
We need to get this in our minds understand it.
And so to get there we need to First understand. What a
Denarius was.
Because that's the standard of measure that Jesus is using here
in this Parable. So what was a Denarius a Denarius
was one day's wage for a common day
labor.
So I just somebody just go into work the fields a day worker.
That was one day's wage. They'd get a Denarius.
So to help us understand, I have a engineering degree.
So I like math in my head. I love this.
So I did a little math to compare our dollars today
to what that would have been back then so a day
labor, let's just assume $10 an hour for ease of math
and and then they work eight hours a day.
If you take all of that together, the first debtor
in this scene would have owed them lender $40,000.
Well, the second debtor would have owed $4,000
right 550 40,000 to
4,000. These were
the two debts that these people could not pay back
to the lender for whatever reason they couldn't pay it back
and that's why the parable here shows us the heart of the
king of the kingdom of God.
Right because Jesus looked at the scandalous
woman at his feet. He looked at Simon over
here self-righteously judging her and him.
Jesus looked at the scene and he gave a picture of
what forgiveness looks like.
So Jesus is telling this Parable and Simon's trapped, right?
He's Trapped In This Moment. He he knows $40,000
$4,000. He knows it's very
clear the answer to the question and he had
to respond to Jesus asking him which one would love
him more by saying, of course the one who had the larger debt forgiven.
They'd feel more grateful.
They'd feel more free. They'd feel more released from
what their their debt was and the weight
of that.
Now here's the reality. They should both feel.
Grateful thankful free because they
had a debt forgiven, right?
But one would comparatively feel more than the
other.
And all that sets up.
The public application that Jesus then gives in response
to the parable.
See the context had been clear that the scene was
set. The parable had been powerfully portrayed Jesus
paints a picture in people's minds and now he applied
it.
We're grateful that he shows us the meaning.
That's what he continues. Look at verses 44 through 48.
He just told the parable Simon understood it. Then turning
to The Woman verse 44 turning to the woman. He
said to Simon so he turns to
the woman, but he's still talking to Simon, right?
He says do you see this woman?
I entered your house Simon you gave me no water
for my feet, but she has wet
my feet with her tears and wiped them with her hair.
You gave me no kiss. But from the time I came
in. She has not ceased to kiss my feet.
You did not anoint my head with oil, but she has anointed my
feet with ointment perfume.
Therefore I tell you her sins, which are many are forgiven.
For she loved much.
but he who was forgiven little loves little
and he said to her your sins are
forgiven.
So notice something here.
The whole time Jesus has been in the house. We don't know how long it was. But
but the whole time he had been allowing all of
this to happen.
to set up this contrast between Simon
and the woman
Because remember Simon was not the only one around that table.
there were other people there who were listening and Jesus
Remember uses Parables to separate those who
are looking for the kingdom of God from those who aren't
So here he's immediately separating. We
see that very clear. Look at the next verse verse 49.
Those who were at table meaning around the table with him began to
say among themselves. Who is this who even forgives
sins?
Like they don't know what they're seeing. They can't understand forgiveness
because they're not looking for the kingdom of God.
He used it to separate to get people to see the nature of the
Kingdom if they're looking for it. They're going to love it. But if they're not they're
going to be confused by it.
And here he puts forward this idea of
what we should do how people should respond to the
to their their understanding of
their sin. If they fully get it that they are sinful to
get in the Kingdom. They have this response. But
Simon over here, he doesn't understand his sin.
So he's not going to respond like this.
That's what Jesus is doing when he compared and contrasted
the responses to Jesus between Simon
and between the woman.
And you see that right? He says Simon.
even in your own house
You did not even offer basic measures of
hospitality like water to wash
off the nastiness off of the guest feet.
but this woman
this woman
comes in off the street and she uses her
own tears and her own hair to wash
Jesus's feet.
Like she's humble. She's serving it
sounds a lot like Jesus with his disciples a few
years later, right?
Just on her face with her own resources.
Simon did not even greet Jesus with a kiss on both
cheeks, which was a standard way to greet those that
you respect that you're welcoming into your house those that
you have a sense of acquaintance with
Didn't even do that. But this woman.
She can't even stand up in jesus' presence
because she's so elated to be with him
that she's cherishing even his feet and that that's
kissing them over and over again which which was
both a sign of honor to this man, but also submission to
her Lord.
and savior
Simon did not even anoint jesus' head
with cheap olive oil which was a standard practice
just as a way to serve other
people.
while the woman
anoints even jesus' feet
with the costly perfume, which
was an extravagant effort. Anyway, an
over the top action was something so valuable
even on his feet.
But you think about it all of those contrasts points us
back to the parable, right?
Jesus tells the parable and then shows the contrast.
That like one debtor who'd been forgiven $40,000
would be so much more grateful than
the one who'd been forgiven. $4,000, right?
It's the same here with Simon and the woman.
That's why Jesus said verse 47. Therefore. I tell you her sins,
which are many are forgiven for she loved much.
But he who is Forgiven little?
loves little
Be careful with this verse though because Jesus here
is not teaching some kind of works based
salvation.
That because she loved him so much because she
did all of these things for him
that he turned around and said, oh, yeah now you're saved.
Because you did that you are saved no look down at
the end verse 50.
In verse 50. Jesus said to the woman your faith has
saved you go in. Peace.
Your faith has saved you that gives
you peace.
What kind of Peace well first piece with God right?
As an enemy of God now brought into relationship peace
with God peace with herself.
Peace with her past of who she had been
right go in peace that you don't have to be that
anymore.
So what Jesus meant then in verse 47 is that though?
She knew she was a big sinner.
She had a bigger savior.
It came to him.
His name was Jesus. And so she loved
him much in response.
Another translation says that her great love
proves that her many sins have been
forgiven.
That's what this means. That's what's her response. But
think here Simon.
Simon on the other hand
He did not really acknowledge his sin, so
he didn't think he needed Jesus.
He might have respected Jesus as a teacher like he
even says here.
But he certainly didn't love him.
He certainly didn't love him like this woman.
But think about it.
think about it could
Simon have been grateful like she
was
Yes.
Right, absolutely.
Because remember Simon had a sin debt
that he could not pay back also.
He needed forgiveness just like she did.
He had sin blinding his heart just like she did.
He's guilty too. He could have been just like
her.
If he had seen Jesus as the Savior if
he had come to Jesus in that
kind of perspective knowing who he is knowing
who Jesus is then his actions would have been a lot
more like hers.
So I think if you have ears to hear what Jesus is saying
here, I think it's it's pretty simple to get the point of
this powerful parable.
But also want us to dig a layer deeper.
To mine out some of the more particular things that
we might not just glance over here at this
scene.
Because not only do we need to understand what Jesus was teaching them. We need to hear what
he's saying to us today.
Like we need to hear what he's telling
us through this scene 2,000 years ago. What
is he saying to us here in
this moment?
What are specific ways this Parable applies
in our lives?
I want to give you three. It's probably more.
But here's three responses as Jesus forgives big
sinners.
Here are three responses.
First we must also
see people deeply.
see people
deeply
see when you read through the gospels Matthew Mark
Luke and John.
You find that if anything was true about Jesus.
It's that he could see people.
Not just look at people.
See people right? There's a difference between those two things.
Let me give you an example. We have the example here, but
let me give you example from Mark chapter 5.
Says a great crowd followed Jesus and thronged about him meaning
pressed in closely and pushed on him and there was
a woman who had a discharge of blood for 12 years who had
suffered much under many Physicians had spent all she
had to try to fix it was no better but rather grew
worse.
She had heard the reports about Jesus and came up behind him
in the crowd and touched His Garment sounds like the woman
in Pharisees house, right?
She touched His Garment for she said if I touch even his
garments, I'll be made well.
and immediately
the flow of blood dried up and she felt in her
body. She was healed of her disease.
And Jesus perceiving in
himself that power had gone out from him immediately turned
about in the crowd and said who touched my
garments.
who touched
and his disciples said to him you see the crowd pressing around you yet. You
say who touched me like everybody's touching you
Jesus?
And he looked around to see who had done it.
But the woman knowing what had happened to or came in fear
and trembling and fell down before him sounds familiar, right?
And told him the whole truth.
And he said to her daughter your faith
has made you well.
Go in peace.
And be healed of your disease.
So again In This Crowd everybody bumping into
each other run like, you know, just this massive people.
Everybody's touching everybody else yet. He
asked the question who singular touched
me.
Who was it who touched me?
So many people around him the crowds yet. He
saw this woman's condition. He saw
her form. He understood her needs
and he met her where she was.
You think he knew she was coming, right Jesus knew
she was going to be there. It wasn't like he was surprised by
something. He knew she was there.
And so the question in light of who Jesus is
the question is, is that where we are, is that
our hearts?
Do we have the same heart Jesus had for people
do we look with compassion? Do we look with empathy?
Are we burdened for the broken for the people
around us?
Do we lock eyes with people who think that they
never get noticed by anybody else?
Do we show Hospitality to
people in ways that hear this actually might
affect our social standing of people around us.
You had them here. What are you doing? Why are you
meeting? Why are you care?
hospitality
welcoming
all people
do we look around and we see people who are different than
us.
Respecting them listening to them and
their experiences.
Remember that Jesus here in the headwinds of
cultural and religious norms.
He saw this woman at his
feet not as anything but a person
who needed forgiveness.
Not what everybody else in the room saw her as what the
world saw her as he saw her as a person
who needed forgiveness, but not only person need forgiveness, but
also someone who could carry that Grace of his love and
forgiveness to other people.
Go in peace. He says.
like the woman at the well
Right, go go tell go share.
I've changed your life go tell everybody about it. Listen
church, let we cannot allow.
Our external environments that we walk around
in.
Nor our internal attitudes towards people.
We cannot allow those things to hinder
our ability to see who God wants us
to see.
Wherever Whenever we are around others
to see people deeply
But listen, you can only get there.
You can only get to that kind of heart. If you follow here
the second response that you must view your self-humbly.
We look at the parable the context the application. We must
view ourselves humbly.
Think again to the parable.
Right the structure of the parable.
Yes.
One of the debtors had a larger debt than the
other person did.
They both had a debt.
right
They both had a debt and they both checked this out.
They both had a debt they couldn't pay back.
40,000 4,000 it says both of
them could not pay so the moneylender looks at them and says I forgive both
of you.
You couldn't pay I forgave you. So since Jesus then
ties the Parable with forgiveness of sins what
that means for each of us today is that all of us are
debtors to?
Each one of us is in that same category of
a debtor that cannot pay back a debt.
That's us every one of us.
Because on our own We Stand guilty before God.
We have this Romans 3:23 sin debt that we can't
pay back to God all have sinned to fall short of the glory of God. We
can't make it. We can't pay it back.
If we recognize that reality.
And we remember that it's not just about comparing ourselves
to other people so that we think we're comparatively better
than they are.
We're not as bad as we thought we were or somebody else might say we
are no I'm better than no. That's not what it's about either when we recognize what
we really are and then
we acknowledge it and we're willing to come to Jesus and
respond to Jesus.
We can move from the category of debtor that
can't pay it back to forgiven debtor.
Right, you understand that you can make it
to this category from the one category. We're all in.
To be a forgiven debtor.
And so check this out in the parable. There's not actually
a lesser debtor category.
We're all debtors. We're all equally guilty when
we compare ourselves to a holy God.
We all have a debt we cannot pay.
And so when we see God like that as holy when
we see ourselves as not holy as sinful
deserving his wrath what that leads
us then to is to see Jesus as even
more glorious.
When we really remember that that he
would come and live the perfect life that we could never live that Holy
life. We could never live. He did it for us. Then he
died the death we deserve for that sin. He came
back from the grave to defeat that sin to defeat
that death. That's the only way to see
that sin debt forgiven.
When we repent of that sin trust in Jesus in our
place, that gives us forgiveness.
And listen that destroys any form of pride
in yourself that you think you could work
it off. You think you could pay it off yourself. You can't
And so it should humble us.
That we needed Jesus to do it for us.
And so it should kill self-righteousness in our hearts.
We should not respond like Simon.
But it also should remove any disdain for
others or any attitude of superiority. We
might have over other people.
Yes Simon disagreed with Jesus that he
didn't think he needed Jesus. But also Simon is looking at this woman like man if
he knew who she was.
And Jesus like do you know who you are, right?
It should kill any attitude of superiority over
other people.
We're all debtors. We're not better than anyone else
in this at all. But that's also one of the most beautiful aspects
of the Gospel.
See the gospel not only takes those of us who
might view ourselves too, highly and it humbles us.
it also takes
you when you feel.
downcast
Cast Away too low it
lifts you up.
the woman
didn't deserve anything.
Jesus lifts her up and says Dottie your faith is saved
you go in. Peace.
It humbles us kills self-righteousness, but
also elevates us beyond anything that
we could ever imagine about ourselves.
It's the gospel beautiful picture of taking
debts and forgiving.
Changes the way with you god changes the way we view
ourselves.
And it changes the way we then treat other people.
Not only should we be quicker to forgive if we've been
forgiven so much. We should also stop rejecting those
that the world and even people around us
might consider outcasts due to their sin.
Think about it this
woman Jesus Jesus knew the reputation that woman didn't he?
Everybody else knew.
Woman of the city woman of the night. She's a sinner.
Jesus would have known who she was yet. He
willingly allowed her to worship him
to honor him to touch him.
As a prophet a priest whatever you
might call up. He's a religious leader and he's supposed to
stay clean, but he allowed her to touch him.
Even as unclean as she was.
And he looked at her and he forgave her and he
saved her.
But you might be sitting out there saying oh, but wait a second hold up. You're supposed to
embrace Sinners here. How what about their sin?
Like does does loving the outcast mean that we approve of
what they're doing?
This woman was was living a sinful lifestyle. Do we
approve of this Jesus approving of that? No, Jesus never approved
of those things. Remember acceptance does
not equal approval.
You can I know it's hard to believe the world doesn't
believe this but it's possible to reject specific actions
yet. Still Embrace sinners.
Because think how else will we be able to help people move
toward faith move toward obedience.
Without a relationship with them somehow.
again, not approval, but we can welcome people
like Christ has welcomed us
Romans 15:7
Because think what he does with you.
He loves us unconditionally.
Yet he calls us out of our sin and toward better.
You can do that. You can love someone and be in relationship with them and
still say get out of that stop for your good
for your family's good for others. Good stop.
Christ is better. Let's walk together towards him. It's possible.
But you can't get there.
without starting
humbly viewing yourself
that you're a debt or two that you're you're payment
your end game is eternity
without God.
Unless he intervened.
You are a debtor. I am a
debtor, too.
So let's view ourselves that way to lead us
to view others differently.
And that leads us to the final.
action step
in response to this Parable and context around it.
See the fact that Jesus forgives big Sinners should also lead
us to worship Him boldly.
to worship God boldly
See people deeply view ourselves humbly worship God boldly.
see when we
truly grasp the depth
of forgiveness
that we are each here this
Each an enemy of God in our sin.
That we are each destined to an eternity without him.
Yet he reached through the darkness and
saved us from that pit.
When we get that that makes us truly different, doesn't
it?
Like there's a woman.
She had obviously heard somehow she heard about
Jesus that that he offered sinners like
her a different life something new and
she responded with overwhelmed Joy,
right?
Like she shed tears all over his
feet.
Because broken in her shame everybody else
told her you're worthless. You're pointless. This is all your
good for you have no hope she was shameful yet.
She was then elated that this man would offer
her forgiveness.
She wasn't afraid what other people thought about her
as she kissed his dirty feet in
honor and submission to our Lord
say
She brought the best she had.
Expensive perfume. She poured it
out in worship to her Lord right there.
Church would anyone describe us?
What have we made our faith all about?
our minds
like Doctrine and complex thoughts and
and we've written emotions completely out
of this thing.
God made us emotional creatures
Now listen, it's right to study and we absolutely should
that's what we do here for 35 minutes every Sunday.
That's what you should do every day. Like we'd get in community groups. We study
God's word. Yes, we should but our study of
God should move our hearts. It should stir
us.
Theology study of God theology should
lead to doxology which is worship.
And we're studying the god of the universe.
Like somehow we started believing that we
can receive God's grace without effect and without
response.
Do we really understand Grace then if we if we
don't feel anything if we're not moved by it in
any way Grace Grace should lead us
to more humility.
to more grateful hearts
to more compassion
for other people
to more bold proclamation of the Gospel to all people
groups to our neighbors.
So why?
Is our response to God so often
lukewarm.
Why are we so calloused so oft?
Why do we often respond to Jesus like Simon
not like the woman?
Why do we just go through the motion In
Worship?
Why does this feel so often
so ritualistic?
Why are we stone-faced through songs proclaiming
the greatness of our God?
Why are we unmoved by the preaching of
the good news of Jesus in our place? Why are
we callous to what other people and the way we treat them
at any matter. We just say what we want to say doesn't matter we speak
and type whatever we want to say.
Why does our commitment to the Lord wane?
Every day it wavers back and forth.
When you think about this parable?
our love grows cold
possibly because we have a very small sense
of the huge debt that we've been.
Forgiven do we really remember what he saved
us from?
With that not make him then the
most important thing in our entire lives
that we don't care what everybody else thinks about the way
we respond to our Savior.
The truth of God's good news sinks
deeply into your soul.
If you remember the depths from which
Jesus has saved you.
Then you will gladly and boldly worship
him no matter what else anyone else thinks.
like this woman
it's broken all week over this woman. Just thinking about
the scene the sobbing mess at Jesus's
feet.
But she's bringing her best to
him because she loved her forgiving
savior so much.
Again, the more you understand what Jesus said The
more you understand what you've been forgiven of the more he will love
much.
You'll be full of gratitude. You will
obey better. You will sing louder you
will give generously you will serve sacrificially when
you get it in your soul the
more and more which by the way, you might think I've been Christian a long time.
How can I grow in this you'll never stop growing even into eternity?
Because you'll discover more about God forever and ever and ever
if he's infinite. You're not you're gonna learn more.
So don't think I got it all figured out you have a lot
to learn.
I have a long way to go yet and I
need to see Jesus and you
will do all of that. If you get in your heart, you'll do all that boldly because
Jesus is completely changed your life. He's made
you a new creation. The old has gone. The newest comes Secretary
of like he's gonna make you and is making you and has made
you completely new forever.
So listen, if you wherever you are, whatever
you are, whoever you are, whatever your past looks like if you
are in that moment like her right now come to Jesus.
It's who he is?
and if you've experienced his forgiveness
What else can you do but worship
him with everything you are?
To give your life to Jesus saying all
of me is all yours God.
It's the point here.
Jesus forgives big sinners
like you and like me.